50 garlic clove mac and cheese for all
the garlic girlies you want to Cone your
50 cloves in a nice olive oil bath at
250 de for about 2 hours until it get
bubbly and tender today we're riffing
off a well- loved tasty mac and cheese
recipe that has more Southern Roots
after buttering and seasoning our Mac we
added five different cheeses mozzarella
provalone smoked Gudda feta and cheddar
with egg and evaporated milk a nice
alternative to flour-based root sauces
from there toss in your garlic comi and
cover the mixture with of course more
cheese and bake at 350° for about 45
minutes until it's nicely Brown and
bubbly I don't know about you but this
February my love language is garlic